great yes where you from
there's tree long you been asking rap
[ __ ] - Douglas what what happened - you
ended up down here just too late you
didn't want to work you didn't like
working yeah so living down here is no
responsibility yet no hassles
you look very simple very simple you go
to the mission to get here yes I do in
breakfast problem yes how about lunch
you know I eat them on the road yeah do
you hang out
yes and what about drugs the drugs are
back we didn't drink beer nothing else
goes on yet
never do you sleep anywhere eat Birgit
am yeah
and then tell me about your childhood I
grew up in a good household repairs they
work no use no abuse no drugs just work
you just don't feel like taking on the
responsibility of work of life and work
and having a job and cambiar all that do
you think you're happy you feel you're
happy this way yes I do yeah you seem
pretty content and we're we're just to
see yourself in five years
oh I couldn't tell you just have my life
it's not necessary you know an apartment
really just doing right did you feel
you're not
yeah like what close a dirty no shower
just doing right yeah you guys do you
have any other camera
no so it's just you yeah were you
another child yes
and Jenny girlfriends or kids no do you
ever have you know you've never had
relationships I've had one relationship
with Laurie and it was a good one lasted
for like a couple years and we wouldn't
borrow separate wait I still talk to her
she's good she's a nice person
she's not very my type
she's sort of fat whether or not we are
do you a friends know me I'm a yoga
friends I got a lot of so she's at home
associate people they see a lot of
mystery
yeah but they're not really know
and your health is good you lose you're
fine yeah and you say drinking weed you
don't get out of control with that a
little you do actually I don't
you have to build you just use avoiding
all the stress of life yeah
take the right city to do that
warmer
you think some crazy stuff down here
it's Gabriel right Oh actually I have it
I've heard about it but I have it female
so you where do you use you tend to stay
away from the drama the drama yes yes oh
so you're sleeping somewhere close to
downtown yeah term missions I'm sorry I
salute I sleep closer to the mission oh
I said they say
[Music]
well thanks for talking to me yeah I
appreciate you say that there
if I tell you a funny joke can I earn
another Tony if I tell you a funny joke
help me out I need another 20 help me
out if I tell you make me laugh I'll
give you another 20 all right can you
hear let's say no see no no the aterna
for you thank you I can walk from here